logan paul wants to shoot his shots with
kendall Jenner the 24 year old YouTube
star recently sat down with Jonathan
shovin for an episode of his podcast
food god OMFG and while Kendall's dating
history leans more towards men who shoot
hoops
instead of videos logan boldly asked the
45 year old who is Kim Kardashian's
bestie if he thinks there's any way the
model would go for him I just want to
ask like do I have a chance with Kendall
mm-hmm I'm not I'm not I'm not like a
full athlete but I don't think so and
you know why and you know why I think
you're too out there and Kendall is very
low-key with the people she dates and
they're low-key so that was just a nice
way of saying not a shot in hell buddy
so if you did they Kendall like the next
day you would like skydive off the
Empire State Building that wouldn't work
for her I had this thing every girl that
I ended up dating there's like a couple
of things one they hate me at first like
that's the number-one thing and that's
why they love you not the Internet
disappointing that is Logan's last
relationship was with agents of shield
star Chloe Bennet but they reportedly
split in October 2018 but back to
Kendall I don't know maybe if I never
get her in a conversation sue happens
and even though Jonathan made it pretty
clear it was not gonna happen
Logan's still had questions to figure
out how compatible they would be is she
cool is she cool she's cool she's very
reserved you know Kenna's very reserved
I known them since they're little kids
even weird for me to talk about yeah but
my question is if she reserved because
like the media and people have made her
reserved no I think that just survived
always and if Jonathan didn't make it
clear the first time he made it crystal
clear the second time around so no
chance no it's okay that's fine that's
fine I know it's just I mean it's a
rejection it's a part of life so why
does Logan suddenly wanna be Kendall's
boo Wow it's ready for the high profile
relationship dawg like when I make a
flirt when I make my bill when I got a
bill in the bank Logan predicted that
bill will be in the bank in six years
when he's 30 years old so mark your
calendar kendall ET recently caught up
with Logan's brother Jake and he said
Logan is ready to settle down and have a
baby
Logan keeps on saying he wants to have a
kid really yeah he's like fools maybe
okay I wouldn't be surprised he's at
first I thought he was like joking about
it he's like every time every day I'd go
to his house he's like man I wanna have
a kid I wanna have a kid and I was like
at first I thought he was joking and
then I like I'm serious yeah you play
like matchmaker with him though when it
comes to like relationships or do you I
don't like to his own thing I do you
know his type and stuff I know its type
yeah yeah I said I actually set him up
with this girl that he's talking to now
really okay is it looking good no they
hate each other huh well Logan did say
girls hate him at first so maybe they're
soul mates
you better believe et will be right here
to keep you up-to-date on all the things
the Paul boys do so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]